slow cooking isn't exclusive to just
savory dishes it's a clever way to
transform fruit into wonderful desserts
giving them an amazing sticky jammy
intensity
invest a bit of patience and my next
recipe pays off big time indulgence and
bursting with flavor caramelized figs
with ricotta slow cooking can also take
desserts to a whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green fix because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious
lay your figs out in rows take some
rosemary and just peel
that down
get that really nice fragrant stem get
your scissors
trim the edge
almost we've got a
bit of a sort of sharp point bring your
three figs together
and just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stalk will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of basil
with
leave them to sit there for five minutes
and this sort of marinade i know it
sounds odd to use vinegar in your
dessert but trust me it gives the dish a
fantastic sweet and sour taste i'm gonna
make a really nice caramel four or five
tablespoons of sugar now flatten that
out and get it nice and even
when the sugar is even caramel cooks
evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in
the one thing you don't do
is shake the pan rapidly
and see it almost like sort of
a lake defrosting and it's hitting to
the center
bubbling
still not dark enough yet
it's getting there turn the gas down and
stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas knob of butter in
there
just gently
whisk in
the butter is cooling the caramel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe lay
next add a log of the balsamic vinegar
nice
beautiful
got that nice
dark
richness of the caramel a little touch
of water in there
that way the caramel doesn't go too
thick
now put the caramel back on the heat
take your figs and sort of place them in
gently
lovely
and then just add all that lovely little
marinade
[Music]
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar embossed on the vinegar
there's something so tasty
baste
those figs
because the
skin
gets nice and crispy on the outside
and the fig sort of just absorbs the
caramel
delicious
so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
the smell
is incredible
onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that caramel
now douse the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese
the freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
i'm gonna finish that now
with some
zest
and then
some little nibbed almonds
and the rich creamy jam texture of the
fig
with the ricotta
is brilliant that is an amazing way of
slow roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
the most amazing tata tan are those pink
peppercorns they are pink peppercorns
they're really good they don't taste
anything like black peppercorns quite
sweet aren't they they're really sweet
very fruity the pink peppercorns give it
the sweetness the black peppercorns give
the heat
now
what is that baby
vanilla
this is one of the easiest desserts in
the world to make but one of the most
delicious it's a sort of take on the
classic
apple or pear to tan but when you
caramelize those bananas with the
peppercorns
and the vanilla i bet that tastes
amazing oh my goodness incredible okay
i'm gonna make the caramel start off
with the coal pen first
and you just press that butter in there
how come do you do it like that and not
let it just melt naturally because i
want the butter to stay cold because i'm
gonna stick the bananas in there okay
and then we'll make the caramel and
caramelize the bananas at the same time
so in goes those
vanilla vanilla seeds pods in there as
well
okay peppercorns done yeah well done
good girl sprinkle them over that butter
just naturally naturally nice and then
look just very carefully
sprinkle sugar
over that
you're doing them all the same size
roughly the same size
wedge it into the butter well do you
know what want the bananas really
caramelized
you just [ __ ] them between
if you crown them in like this okay it
will stop them moving around
nothing's moving nothing is okay so all
wedged in there
sprinkle the peppercorns on top of the
bananas so you've got that flavor
in the caramel and on the top and the
bottom
right
puff pastry
puff pastry is difficult and time
consuming to make so i always buy
ready-made when i'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all-butter type and keep your
pastry cold before using it
and this is where it gets really
exciting you get your fingers you just
pinch the end so you thin the end if you
can do that for me very carefully you
have to be quick because the heat of
your fingers can melt the pastry how
comes you do it
because we get it nice and thin so we
can clip it underneath
now take a spoon
and what we do is lift up that banana
and tuck it underneath
see lift up a little parcel like a
parcel and see the thin bits of pastry
yeah how easy it is to get it underneath
yeah and that's why you thin them out
you do it so quickly well because i have
to be quick otherwise the pastry will
melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry that's right
see how locked down that is
[Music]
gas on
we'll start caramelizing that
those three little holes are so
important
if we didn't put a hole in the pastry
and it will cause a lot of steam so the
pastry never cooks it just goes really
soggy okay so really important the
caramel is live now we're working the
camel give a little shake how can you
see the caramel through the pastry look
what happens when it tilts oh yeah see
all comes running down
see yeah i see
now that pastry
okay is like clinging on to the bananas
and so when we turn it upside down we've
got this glove full of these caramelized
bananas
look at that
wow
it looks like it look a locky
look a locky ah looking likey
got you now baby
you're sorry
i'm sorry
it's your birthday soon 15.
i just worked out
on my 50th
you're 18.
perfect we should do a joint party yeah
love it twelve two four for the old ones
twelve luncheons have time till four for
the old one so they can go to sleep
megan will go on later come on perfect
here's where i get excited now look at
the color of that caramel
so tilt the pan again see how dark it is
now yeah wow it's going a lot darker now
it didn't take long didn't take long at
all that's nearly ready for the oven
wow look at that
so
see now where that pastry is
caramelising caramel so dark and just
a little tip
gas back on
and that will release it
because if you tip it and it's still
sticking
then some of your bananas
will stick yeah so now see when it
starts spinning around like that
moving around
and here we are the moment of truth
when you know your daddy
is the best chef in the world
ready
yeah
wow
look at the vanilla
how delicious
amazing smells really good as well
delicious
poached pears i love pizza ready so
we're gonna poach them with a little bit
of chili
chili
never heard of that no but a saffron no
no
no pan on
take off a little slice like that so
they stand up nicely and then peel
okay then and then the chilli you hold
that up and just go down yep
through
and open that up okay into the water
seeds in as well seeds them as well
oh hollow holes
where is that smell it smells so good
you got the most amazing
are you well yeah
a little bit of chilli
water and sugar what are they holes
saffron is expensive but you only need
the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star nice how come it's
the chinese you've like sliced it at the
end and it's not put in whole i want all
that flavor coming out of the chili
we're gonna make
the most amazing star in east dust sorry
stars dust
so you get your star nice in there
seed
up and then
in
see all those little seeds yeah
and then
you start grinding
a little teaspoon of ginger give it a
nice mix thank you meg and that's gonna
dust the top of the pears once they're
cooked
ryan get your pears
drop them in there
and that's what we're going to sprinkle
mmm
ginger that's darwinis wow what rice is
that
you're very good
that's lovely isn't it so once they're
cooked
cool down sprinkle that over the top
right have you guys got homework yes see
you guys come back shortly thank you so
much
turn that down and let them fall
okay bye thank you guys bye
after an eight minute simmer our pears
should be ready
now just get your knife on put the knife
through and see how easy the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can leave them in that overnight
two or three days all right and they
just get darker
and more beautiful
the good thing about the cooking liquor
is that you don't throw that away
because you can use that again for
re-poaching
beautiful
i mean they look impressive they smell
delicious
[Music]
look at the colors nice lovely isn't it
those are amazing one
and just
and then take your little
star and east dust
and just
dust
over and look at that nice lovely now
for my favorite part my next recipe has
only two main ingredients but simplicity
doesn't mean food can't taste out of
this world
incredible griddle pineapple with spiced
caramel
if you're making a dessert for one or
two it's gonna be quick and easy this
sumptuous delicious griddle pineapple
fits the bill perfectly
pineapple
a way of testing it's nice and ripe
top of the leaves come out perfect ready
to go
always cut a pineapple with a serrated
edge knife
slice off the bottom
turn it back over
and slice the top part
now
keep that
for later
look at the core
the center of the pineapple and slice
down
directly in half
slice that in half
take each quarter and slice them
smells incredible
lay down flat and just slice
that core off
so you've got this perfect
sort of boat of pineapple
slice underneath
but stop
as you get
right at the end slicing around the skin
will make the pineapple easier to eat
but leaving it attached gives you more
control as it cooks
next heat a griddle pan as hot as you
can
start off
in the corner and push it down
so you really mark the pineapple
two minutes on each side
and then just
turn them
really nice color man look at that
beautiful
i'm gonna sprinkle them
with a little touch of sugar that's
gonna glaze them
now
slice the top
take out these beautiful glazed
slices of pineapple
there
next up the spiced caramel
now start off with your pan
nice and hot sprinkle
four tablespoons of sugar in there
just flatten it
then add the seeds from a fresh vanilla
pod
in
a small dusting of chinese my spice
never stir caramel
let it sort of bubble and transform
here she goes
now i've got the color i want it that's
the perfect color off with the gas
in with the butter and then
a couple of tablespoons of cream
lovely and then give that
a little whisk add the rest of your
cream
nice and just
drip
that spicy caramel
over your pineapple
[Music]
wow
simple elegant and seriously impressive
griddle pineapple with spiced caramel a
delicious treat all to yourself that
tastes even better shared
you